це Міхаель Мюллер уявімо що це
пересічний німець Ось він прокидається
снідає і збирається на роботу
[музика]
Ми приєднаємося до нього під час
робочого дня Чим він займається скільки
він заробляє і чи Закоханий він у когось
з офісу дізнаймося ми його зараз
загубимо схоже він пішов у ту сторону Я
його бачу як і наш Міхаель більшість
німців залишають домівку і йдуть
працювати в офіс 10% добираються туди на
велосипедах однак Німеччина відома як
країна автолюбителів тому більшість
німців надає перевагу добиранню автівкою
77,5% німців долають до 25 кілометрів
дорогою на роботу і 40% з них зізнаються
що їздять на роботу менше ніж за 5
кілометрів зима в Німеччині холодна
70% німців добираються на роботу менше
ніж за 30 хвилин а подорожуючи
автомобілем вони проводять у заторах до
58 годин на рік
лише 25% німців працюють принаймні
частково або повністю з дому але коли
Справа доходить до майбутнього місця
роботи то 65% німців хочуть поєднувати
роботу вдома та в офісі
у Німеччині заведено вітатися коли
заходиш у ліфт
згідно з німецькою радою з етикету у
ліфті слід утриматися від надмірної
кількості балачок ви бачили яка вчора
була погода ввечері дощ Злива гриміло
блискало говорити телефоном Привіт мам і
згадувати потенційні катастрофи що
станеться якщо ліфт впаде що ми будемо
робити Може нам просто стрибнути поки
він не впав
і менше ніж на робота є найбільш
поширеною
щойно прийшов у типовий німецький офіс
середньостатистичний штатний працівник
Він працюватиме 40 цілих чотири десятих
години цього тижня Тобто по 8,8 годин на
день Він заробляє 22 євро та 65 центів
на годину і за статистикою є 50% шансів
що він затримається на роботі
[оплески]
70% німецьких офісних працівників
прикрашають свої столи сьогодні Міхаель
привіз фотографію зі свого останнього
походу як і дві третини німців Міхаель
знаходиться в кабінеті сам або у двох з
кимось сьогодні Юлія теж тут
привіт
[музика]
32% німецьких співробітників зізнаються
що цілували колегу а офіс на літня
вечірка була лише Минулого тижня близько
полудня 59% німців люблять вітати один
одного словами
що перекладається як обід або смачного
64% німців кажуть що ніколи не купують
їжу в робочій їдальні більшість полюбляє
приносити обід з дому зазвичай беруть
бутерброди салати та залишки вчорашньої
вечері економно
[музика]
більшість німців витрачають на обід від
15 до 30 хвилин Міхаель з’їв бутерброди
за 13,2 хвилини Отже Він має час випити
кави
вона
в середньому німці випивають 4 чашки
кави на день для Міхаеля це лише третя
[музика]
михайлю подобається його робота
насправді 60% німців задоволені своєю
роботою і 29 відсотків дуже задоволені
зараз 5 вечора що означає феєрабенд у
Німеччині феєрабенту означає кінець
робочого дня
[музика]
Куди йде Міхаель Він збирається на
побачення залишайтеся з нами щоб
дізнатися більше про життя
середньостатистичних німців
[музика]